there's unlimited people who got
straight A in their life and are
dramatically more successful than me I'm
not even worried about the successful
part financially I'm desperately
petrified that most people don't
understand how to become successfully
emotionally I promise you at the end of
the day your parents as you get older
will be much happier that you're happy
versus how much income you make parents
get caught up in the game I'm empathetic
to it parents need to spend more time
looking at people 20 or 30 years older
than them and realize that there's
unlimited parents right now in their 70s
and 80s who are devast stated that their
children are unhappy but they happen to
be great lawyers and doctors and
successful businessmen and women I
promise you both your parents and this
incredible institution will be okay
whether you get straight A's or B's or
C's or that I think the bigger question
is do you know yourself there's
unlimited people who are successful and
happy they got straight A's and there's
happy who got D's and Fs the question is
who are you who do you want to be and I
think that's what you need to focus on
cuz that's going to lead to much better
outcomes for the next 100 Years of your
life than whether you get A's or FS